adroit sens pour retrouver marie louise
fort maire sortante qui est donc ce soir
en ballottage pour un éventuel deuxième
tour de scrutin
marie louise fort une une réaction à
votre résultat ce soir
écoutez je suis satisfaite de mon
résultat puisque je suis largement en
tête et simplement je voudrais quand
même signaler que comme partout en
france le score dés de participation est
très bas ça tient à la situation
sanitaire du pays et je le regrette
infiniment d'autant qu'on peut se poser
légitimement la question de savoir si la
semaine prochaine on sera en état et non
pas en confinement d'aller voter pour un
second tour
donc c'est quand même très préoccupant
pour ce qui concerne puisque c'est la
question que vous me posez quand même
mon score écoutez je suis satisfaite que
les cenonnaise et les sénonais mais mis
en en tête ce qui veut dire que notre
bilan est plutôt bon et puis que il
souhaite aussi la continuité de l'action
de l'équipe sortante renouvelé